what's going on people in this video
we're about to break down episode 20 of
attack on titan season 4 in which aaron
used the true power of his attack titan
to directly influence the past
this was by far the most complex use of
titan abilities that we've ever seen and
today i'll be explaining exactly how it
happened and also how erin knew this
moment was coming for over four years
before we get into it though i do these
breakdowns every week so i'd really
appreciate if you hit that sub button if
you haven't already and as usual drop a
like if you like the video
okay so in the last episode z gained
control of the founding titan which
gives him power over every single elden
on the planet
with this potential he could finally
complete his euthanization plan and
sterilize all subjects of emir however
being the amazing brother that he is he
only wants to do this with erin by his
side in zeke's mind he assumes the
reason aaron betrayed him is because he
was brainwashed by grisha to become an
alien restorationist which is of course
what happened to zeke himself when he
was growing up for that reason he uses
the power of the founder to take them
into grisha's memories so he can make
aaron realize that he's been manipulated
by their father the first flashback they
visit is one of erin crawling and being
held as a baby and i don't know about
you guys but if i didn't know for a fact
this was him then i would have just
assumed this was a girl regardless of
that now is probably the best time to
establish the rules of travelling
through memories and rule number one is
that the jagabros are not actually
traveling into the past but rather this
is more like a simulation created by the
founding titan in this simulation they
can witness key moments from grisha's
life but no one can see them back since
everyone is basically an npc this brings
us to rule number two which is that
because all of these memories are just
visual representations of things that
took place it means that zeke and aaron
should not be able to change how
anything plays out we'll get back to
this topic later on to explain how aaron
did what he did but for the time being
let's focus on grisha himself
in this memory we can see that he used
his position as a doctor to get close to
nobles inside the walls and this is one
of the reasons why kruger thought he'd
make a good spy as a doctor with
knowledge from the outside world grisha
was one of the best if not the best on
the island and he'd already saved the
people of shiganchena from a plague a
few years earlier this accomplishment is
most likely how important people inside
the walls heard of him and by getting
close to them grisha could eventually
find out who has the founding titan
while observing this memory zeke thought
that this was just another example of
how his dad was a terrible person since
if his plan had been discovered then it
would have obviously put his new family
at risk despite that aaron wasn't so
convinced and as they continued to move
through these memories it became clear
that grisha did learn from the mistakes
he made when raising zeke that was
proven in this particular flashback when
after only a few years on parodies he
managed to discover the identity of the
true royal family in this scene he
approaches the rice chapel and prepares
to confront the royals and steal the
founding titan but in the end he
couldn't go through with it and returns
to his family back home what this showed
is that he loved his new son too much to
risk losing everything which is in
direct contrast to how he treated zeke
and was prepared to make his first son a
soldier for an enemy state in that way
grisha had clearly grown as a person and
it would be a long time until he decided
to visit the rice chapel again
before we continue there were a few bits
of trivia i wanted to mention the first
being that at this point in the timeline
the king of the walls was uri rice this
means that had grisha gone down into the
basement that day he would have ended up
fighting him instead of frieda and it's
feasible the fight might have ended
differently after all uri was shown to
have lining fast reflexes during his
encounter with kenny ackerman and at
this time he would have had his shifter
for around six or seven years making him
far more experienced than freda was when
she was defeated
another piece of trivia was that in this
memory when grisha discovered the map to
the rice chapel he then crossed paths
with kenny who was now being employed by
the royal family had kenny found out
what he was hiding in his pocket then
there's a solid chance he might have
tried to slice his neck which may or may
not have led to grisha turning into a
titan so it's just a good thing for
everyone that he was able to leave
without being questioned
now moving on to one of the best scenes
in the episode we see that grisha fell
asleep in his basement while writing one
of his famous books in his sleep he
starts to receive memories from the
future that belong to present day erin
and we're gonna pause for a second to
explain what exactly is going on
to start things off it's fairly normal
for a time shifter to see memories that
belong to a previous user but when it
comes to holders of the attack titan
these guys are sometimes able to see
memories from their future inheritance
as well
one example is how back in season 3
kruger told his successor to save mikasa
and armin despite neither of them being
born yet and now in this new episode a
similar thing happens again
because aaron and his dad are both
holders of the attack titan grisha from
the past is therefore able to see
memories that belong to aaron in the
future
in this specific scene notice how when
aaron looks down at this picture of zeke
his dad then immediately reacts and
apologizes to his first son
then when present-day aaron looks
directly at his raggedy bearded brother
grisha from the past reacts again as he
sees a vision of a bearded man who he
recognizes as zeke
what this shows is that thanks to his
attack titan grisha can occasionally see
the future through eren's point of view
and as the video continues we'll break
down how this ability enables them to
communicate through time
anyway after seeing everything so far
zeke finally realizes that his
assumptions were wrong and their father
didn't bring much aaron to become an
alden restorationist because of this
zeke begins to wonder why aaron then
betrayed him and acts the way he does
since he's doing all the things his
father would have wanted only without
ever being told to do so aaron goes on
to explain that no one had to make him
this way and that since birth he's just
always had this drive to protect his own
freedom no matter what the cost
in this memory here we get a look at the
crime scene after eren amikusa killed
those kidnappers and it was kind of
funny seeing zeke and his dad reacting
the same way
this moment here emphasized just how
different the two jaegerbros are since
zeke's backstory made it clear that he
was content to live a life inside the
internment zone whereas by contrast
aaron is someone who felt confined by
the walls and was quite literally
willing to kill people who threatened
his freedom
with this difference in character now
being established you might then be
wondering why zeke continued to take
them through their dad's memories and
the answer is that he still believed he
could change aaron's mind in the same
way that sarva once saved him he is now
desperate to save aaron and so he's not
going to carry out the euthanization
plan until he finds at least one memory
that might change his brother's
perspective
as they walk through flashback after
flashback we get moments that are subtly
relevant to things that grisha says
later in the episode for example in this
memory he's taking care of children in
his office and then later when he
confronts the wright's family he
collapses to his niece saying that he
could never kill kids
another instance is how he casually
walks past this father and son playing
with a ball which is something zeke
always wanted to do and later grisha
basically apologizes for never doing
this
eventually they get to this memory of
their dad putting the finishing touches
on his notebooks and as he looks at the
key he senses a presence in the room
this is another example of him receiving
a memory from the future cause with
aaron staring directly at him past
grisham would have briefly seen a vision
of himself from his son's point of view
to reinforce this point it's worth
remembering that although he previously
commented on zeke's appearance he never
once mentions what future eren looks
like and that's because he doesn't
actually see his younger son
given that the visions he's receiving
are coming directly from aaron's own
eyes then it makes perfect sense why he
can strongly feel a presence but can't
physically see him back
anyhow the next flashback is one from
the very first episode of the series and
thanks to everything we know this scene
now has a completely different meaning
in this moment grisha asks his son why
he wants to join the survey corps to
which aaron replies that he wants to
know what it's like on the outside and
that if there's no one to carry on all
the deaths up until now will be in vain
that second line is super important
because although aaron was talking about
the previous scouts who died in grisha's
mind he was thinking about something
else in this moment he realized that if
he died without completing his mission
or passing on his shifter then the
deaths of kruger diner and all the other
restorationists would be in vain it was
these words from his son that convinced
grisha to go and finally confront the
royal family that day and coincidentally
it also happened to be the same day the
warriors attacked
this coincidence was confirmed later in
the episode when he spells out that he
didn't know which day the wars were
going to be destroyed
switching back to the memory in question
we then get a replay of the scene where
he promises to show erin what's in the
basement this time around the camera
pans out to reveal aaron's standing
there watching the moment play out and
because of grisha's future memory
inheritance he feels the presence in
front of him again just like he did in
the basement
he then makes his final journey to the
rice chapel almost a decade after he
first attempted to confront them and
this sequence was undeniably the best
part of the episode as he begs frida to
save the people of the island from the
titans outside the walls you can see
that she does genuinely have some
concern for what he's saying since the
real friederich wanted to save humanity
on parodies
however it wasn't long until she was
overtaken by the will of carl fritz who
began ranting about how eldians should
accept their fate because if they die it
means that fewer people outside the
walls have to suffer
this way of thinking is very similar to
zeke which is why he had no complaints
about what she said but on the other
hand aaron was getting angrier and
angrier as she kept talking remember
this memory is taking place on the same
day his mother was eaten by a titan and
here you have someone trying to justify
her death and the death of everyone else
who was killed by the warriors his
intense feelings of rage could be felt
by his dad in the past hence why he
reacts in this moment and it's about
time we break this moment down step by
step
point number one is that when this
really happened all those years ago
grocers attack titan enabled him to
receive memories from this version of
eren the memories he received in this
scene were essentially a live stream
from aaron's perspective meaning that
grisha was experiencing this one moment
from both his own point of view and from
aaron's point of view as well he could
feel the same emotions his son was
feeling and see the same things his son
was seeing a connection made possible by
the attack titan
point number two is that zeke took his
brother into this memory without knowing
this ability was a thing so while zeke
could only watch on it was aaron
specifically who had the power to
communicate with their dad that's why
when grisha drops to his knees and
hesitates to kill the royal family his
son tells him to stand and then that
memory of him saying that is sent into
the past where his dad receives the
message
using this method error motivates his
father by giving him a speech that is
heavily inspired by the one kruger gave
13 years ago and as it turns out this is
exactly what grisham needed to hear to
go ballistic and massacre the rice
family
an interesting thing to note is that we
got this shot of eren kissing historia
which is a reference to the medal
ceremony four years ago
during that ceremony aaron experienced
all of his father's memories from the
rice chapel including the memories that
grisha received from the future
what this means in reality is that four
years ago aaron didn't just see his
dad's memories but he also saw memories
that were sent to his dad by future
versions of himself
ever since he kissed the hand he knew it
was him that motivated his father to
kill the rice's and on top of that he
saw a different memory that made him
make this face
if you're wondering what that other
memory could be then we need to flash
forward to after grisha emerges from his
titan body and a nice detail was that he
took this syringe from the rice chapel
which he would later use on eren
regardless of that the main point here
is that in this scene grisha confirms
that he's seen memories from a future
version of aaron that's even further in
the future than the eren we've seen
based on the context of what he's saying
it shouldn't be hard to guess what he's
talking about here and because aaron
from the medal ceremony saw everything
grisha saw it means this same vision was
shown to him as well
as a quick side note before we continue
i just thought it would be funny to
highlight how much of a coward rod rice
was during this whole interaction since
with his wife and children being in
potential danger he was somehow the
first one to try and make an escape this
cowardice was displayed again many years
later when he wanted historia to shorten
her lifespan by inheriting the founder
instead of simply doing it himself
now moving on we've established that in
the rice chapel grisha saw two sets of
future memories the first set of future
memories belonged to this errand and
they gave grisha the resolve he needed
to kill the royal family while the
second set of future memories belonged
to an errand that we haven't even seen
yet and those memories showed him
something terrible another thing we've
established is that four years ago when
aaron kissed historia's hand he saw all
of grisha's memories from the chapel
which included those two sets of
memories from the future as a result
he's known for a long time about this
terrible future that's meant to happen
and it's heavily implied that aaron
himself is the cause
with that said the last two questions
from this episode that i thought might
need explaining were how was grisha able
to hug zeke and why would he still give
aaron the founding titan despite not
wanting the future he saw to happen
to answer that first question because
aaron is staring directly at his brother
it means that his dad is able to see
where zeke is just like when they were
in the basement he then goes to hug his
son since he knows where zeke is
standing in relation to himself and in
the past dimension this seems to result
in contact i'm sure if someone in the
past was to walk by they wouldn't
actually see zeke in fact all they see
is grisha hugging thin air but because
we're seeing this in the past dimension
it gives off a powerful illusion that
this is really happening of course it
needs to be said that this is only
possible because of the attack titan's
power since if their dad had any other
shifter then he wouldn't be able to see
the future through aaron's eyes
this emotional moment was enough for
zeke to acknowledge grisha as his dad
because we've known all along that he
wanted his fatherly love and the reason
he had all this hatred inside him is
since he never truly received it until
now
finally the biggest remaining question
coming out of this episode is why would
grisha still give aaron the attack titan
if he didn't want the terrible future he
saw to happen
this is a mystery that has at least
three separate valid reasons and yeah
i'm going to start with the one that's
the most obvious during this scene when
he asked zeke to stop aaron grisham had
no idea that earlier that day his wife
had been eaten by a titan if we flash
forward to the moment he finds out his
expression completely changes and the
first words he says are that aaron needs
to avenge his mother grisha knows more
than anyone on the island that marley
are the ones responsible for destroying
the walls but with his time as the
attack titan running out the only person
who can avenge carla is aaron this
brings us to reason number two which is
that due to the curse of emir grisha had
to pass his shifter to someone and he
already established that his son might
be a good choice
earlier he realized that aaron had a
strong desire to be free which is an
integral part of being the attack titan
and it's why he was prepared to tell his
son the truth about the world
to put it simply if he didn't pass it to
eren then there was no one worthy that
he could pass it to and if he didn't
give it to anyone then there's a chance
the shifter would have fallen into
marley's hands after his death since the
power would be inherited by a newborn
eldian anywhere in the world
he must have figured it was a safer
option to give it to his son and
hopefully in the future things can work
themselves out
finally the third reason he chose to
make this decision is that not doing so
would have created a paradox since
grisha already knows that future aaron
possesses the attack titan if he
willingly chose to avoid this future
then he had no idea what would have
happened i mean for all he knows he
might have started fading away because
if eren never gets the attack titan then
future aaron wouldn't have been there to
motivate grisha in the chapel either way
grisha had no way of knowing what would
happen if he didn't follow the
predetermined path so this is likely a
factor in why he did what he did
anyway people that was my breakdown for
episode 20 of attack on titan season 4
and i hope it cleared some things up as
the shifter abilities can get super
confusing if you enjoyed the video then
i'd appreciate if you hit that sub
button and let me know in the comments
what you thought of the episode until
the next one
peace out